- Mindset and execution,
clouds and fucking dirt, motherfuckers.
Clouds and dirt.
The number one mistake
that people are making
in life today is they're
living life in the middle
and I just say fuck the middle.
♪ I've got that lightnin' inside me ♪
- [Gary] You know, 99.9% of the people
that watch or listen to this content
are living in the middle.
They're hedging and making excuses
and justifying why they are not 100% happy
and when you understand
that you have to go
to the heights of heights and figure out
why are you doing this?
How do you want to be remembered?
How does it make you feel?
Are you trading on a currency
that is greater than money?
Do you have the ability when
you have all the leverage
to have the empathy to
give the other person
the upper hand?
Do you understand the game?
♪ This is how legends are made ♪
- [Gary] Are you pulling
from opposite directions
for 13 hours, 19 hours, 24 hours
of mentality and execution that it takes
to achieve your goals?
Do your actions match your ambition?
Do you understand the clouds, the mission,
where you're going, the reasons why
and do you understand the dirt
that creates the diamonds
that we all strive for?
♪ This is how legends are made ♪